i realized that i've been on
two of the longest running shows ever
gun smoke and law order
wow also national bridges and grey's
anatomy grey's anatomy it's gone 18
years of nash bridges you've done yes
you played his wife right i played his
first wife his first one two wives all
right i was the first one was he fun to
work with
don johnson oh my god i remember it yeah
he was great to work with really he yeah
well i've known him a long time he and
my one of my very my boyfriend bruno
kirby who i was with her eight years
they had done a movie together called
the howard experiment
um which is where don met melanie
through her mother tippy hundred who was
in um
the harrod experiment
so uh i knew them i mean i would go
you're like almost royalty well i just
know i've just been around so well i
mean it's just kind of you know you've
worked with a lot of gyms so
i'm really lucky and and and i just
i'm tickled by it too you know i i just
i i still i'm not over the the um
excitement of just being part of this
world you still love acting oh i love
acting more than i've ever loved acting
why
i just
maybe now that you know i i had my
children in there now off and everything
and so my focus is is on
primarily on my work you know michael
too but he's he's the same way i am it's
like we we can't imagine retiring
and it's nice now because i don't have
as much competition for roles all these
other women you know decided i don't
want to do this anymore this is stupid
they bow out well yeah because they're
smart they they
you know they say i want my life i want
to be able to do what i want to do when
i want to make an appointment i want to
get a dog so you're taking all the rolls
well yeah i am taking all the rules
all those juicy mother grandmother rolls
now
uh no but i'm really lucky i'm i'm on
the show that shoots in vancouver again
i'll never leave vancouver um that's
where we did smallville yes uh called
virgin river yes it's just
it's just just happening right it it no
we just finished our fourth season
fourth season yeah there's so many
[ __ ] that's just say f-bomb sorry
about that you get safe bombs i don't
really you don't really i've never heard
you saying that oh my god i say it all
the time
i'm really saying this is ridiculous i
have to stop doing it can you say one
f-bomb for me no i'll bleep it i'll i'll
throw it in somewhere when you release
it wait
that would be great so you're getting
roles you love acting now and you've got
this
rejuvenation of like yeah just what a
cool thing and i get to go to new york
we have an apartment in new york so i
get to go there and they hire us as
locals so that's nice because there's a
lot that shoots in new york yeah did you
ever experience like i'm sure you did
being a woman in this industry being hit
on being taken advantage of did that
happen a lot to you i maybe i was so
stupid i didn't pick up on it i was
really really naive really yeah i'd have
producers call me at home and say you
want to come to vegas for the weekend i
said well can i bring my boyfriend
i'd say that and they go no they'd say
no that would you really
oh they like me
they want to put me in a show
no
you never in your whole career had any
feeling moment where you're like this
guy's
perv i had one you did
yes and i can't say who it is although
he's passed away very recently he was a
director right who who expected me i it
was a meeting in a hotel room and that
was not unusual right you go to
somewhere and meet because because they
he was from out of town they'd go to you
know they'd have a nice suite or
something you go meet them but you know
you've gone to casting um couches not
cows and couches you know meetings yes
and because the people are out of town
right yeah and so they have it the in in
a room at the hotel so that to me it
wasn't weird and i knew the person who'd
set it up is totally on the level and
but i walk in and it's like
you know get
come over here you know
you know it was like oh my god and
you're like no no the thing that upset
me most was i thought oh
he really doesn't want to cast me in
this movie
i get it right it didn't it hurts it
hurts it was like oh this is what i'm
here for how dare he and so i told the
the person who'd set it up and
he was shocked